Vanessa Bryant announced a new tribute
for her daughter Gianna she revealed on
Instagram that Mama Sports Foundation
will be getting a new name
mama mentality is it's a way of life the
organization started by Kobe Bryant will
now be called the Mamba and Mamba Sita
Sports Foundation
Vanessa wrote quote we hope to empower
young athletes in a world they left us
all to help shape this news comes just a
few days after a teen learned a private
funeral for both Kobe and Gianna took
place on Friday a public memorial is
scheduled for February 24th at Staples
Center in downtown Los Angeles it's a
meaningful date for Kobe's legacy 24 was
Kobe's jersey number for the final years
of his career playing for the Lakers
last week Vanessa attended a tribute to
her late 13 year old daughter Gianna
sharing pics and video of Gigi's Jersey
retirement ceremony at Harbor Day School
in Corona del Mar California heartfelt
speeches were given by Gianna's
classmates teachers and her basketball
coach
and gg1 was one of the fiercest
competitors that I've ever seen
[Music]